blake smith congratulations you're
moving forward in the third and final
round of our competition where we're
sending you back to your home forges to
build an iconic weapon from history now
i'm gonna apologize in advance because i
didn't choose this blade
that was up to jay
blade smith you didn't think i was gonna
start taking it easy on you now did you
no
i want you to build this
[Music]
i'm getting to know chris
the maguindanao chris traces its origin
back to the 14th century mindanao the
second largest island in the philippines
this double-edged sword is defined by
its distinct waves designed to inflict
wide deadly slashes in combat
the amount of waves in the warrior's
weapon also indicates your status within
the tribe
the more waves the higher the rank the
chris was the most common moral sword
and many can be seen today in museums
across the world including the
metropolitan museum of art in new york
city you'll have four days of your home
forge to build your blades good luck
gentlemen we'll see you then all right
good luck
john blankman from avon utah i'm a fire
sprinkler contractor i love
bladesmithing because at this point in
my life i'm stuck behind a desk most of
the time and this allows me to get back
out and do things with my hands and it's
just
fulfilling and they're throwing curves
at us curves are not my thing i haven't
done them but i'm pretty confident i can
get this thing done
we're gonna start getting the curves
into the the blade itself then taking a
lot of weight off of it so now i set up
some jigs to get these curves bent into
the blade so at any given moment when
you're putting these radical of a bend
in it your steel could rip and have a
tear in it
you got to kind of cross your fingers
that you're doing it right that should
work so the blades come along really
nice it's in pretty good shape where i
want it to be
oh crap
got a little bit of a crack here
seriously if i can't get this crack
ground out then this is junk
okay
finally i get to the bottom of it and it
is still savable and i don't have to
start over things are going along pretty
good try to get the blade polished up a
little bit get the handle put on to it
got to get it etched and finish it up
looking good all right got it all
sharpened up let's go out and give her a
quick test
i'm feeling great about what i've
accomplished
i do believe that's all i can do
i'm dale branigan from shelby north
carolina i design technology systems for
banks and financial institutions i like
forging for the escape get to hit things
with hammers and play with fire
still's moving uh slow press is a little
weak keeps bending it all over the place
so
i have to keep straightening it out
we're getting there that's starting to
look like a crisp
handle material is pretty close to shape
already all right the handle is glued up
the epoxy's set doesn't look bad now
that i'm going to wrap the handle with
hemp it's not a requirement but it'll
give a good grip and it looks kind of
cool i have a completed weapon just to
turn in with something complete at the
end of these rounds is kind of a feat so
i'm super happy that i'm done
basements welcome to the keel test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
chris and deliver some lethal blows on
this big carcass
john you're first you ready for this
all right let's do this
ah sweet
all right giants talk about your maginot
chris here i really appreciate that you
have this large flare because
it's a very forward heavy blade
but because of that weight and a very
sharp edge you have here these are very
very deep cuts on this big carcass it'll
keel
cool
dale your turns are you ready that's
what i'm here for all right let's do
this
[Music]
[Music]
and jump
all right day let's talk about your
maginda now chris
first stop it's a lot lighter
now that allows me to use velocity to
cut down a pig like this with the same
amount of strikes the edge will cut
deeply and overall sir your weapon
it will keel awesome
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
one of my personal favorites the ice
block chop
i'm going to take your chris swords and
try to free those masks we're going to
have some fun
john you're first you ready to go i am
gonna make snow cones
we could do that
hmm
nice work john
love the damascus
um
very heavy it tears through the ice but
if the ice blocks was any bigger it'd be
tearing through me too
and you got a bit of a warp but
still razor sharp good job
thanks
dale you ready to go
if anybody's gonna break my sword it
might as well be you hey i appreciate
that let's do it
[Music]
dale nice job
the only complaint i have
is your
wrap here is loose
but
everything's so tight your edge is good
nice job nice jay
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test the palm slice
to find out how sharp your weapons are
i'm going to take your maginot crystals
and try to cut through these palms
john you're up first you ready for this
i am
[Music]
nice
[Music]
all right john talk about your weapon
here first up your edge is still very
sharp she said the weight of this has me
holding on to it because i don't want
this to be flying around but for this
particular test
it will cut thank you
daily returns are you ready slice it up
all right will do
[Music]
all right tails talk about your maginda
now chris here it's thin and razor sharp
definitely the type of edge you want in
cutting these brushes and overall sir
your edge
you will cut thanks doug
well placements before we get into the
hard part i want to say it's been a
pleasure watching both of you guys work
there's been a lot of twists and turns
in jay's challenge
but this is a competition and there's
only one champion
the fortune fire champion today is
dale congratulations john you did a
fantastic job but unfortunately your
chris isn't going to end up on the wall
your time this competition has ended i'm
gonna have to ask you to please step off
the fourth floor all right it's been a
great experience man appreciate it thank
you john this whole journey with forging
fire has been incredible
well dale congratulations man that means
you're the newest fortune fire champion
you just won yourself a check for ten
thousand dollars well done
i'm i'm blown away super proud literally
the day before i started that was five
years of the day that i let my first
forge no kids so who knew five years
later you'd be a fortune fire champ
everybody who knows that you make knives
asks when you're gonna be unfortunate
fire now i can tell them not only have i
been on fortune fire but i won a j
nielsen
challenge
you